tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video
sono fa vj oggi siamo finalmente in un
nuovo blog da tipo secoli che non ne
faccio uno registrato qualche pezzo dai
blog mentre ero in america proprio
niente direi che posso lasciarvi al
video
si no ho sbagliato se io direi che
possiamo passare direttamente al video
hanno aperto la gabbia è la gente inizia
a correre
[Applauso]
diciamo ragazzi del blitz con molto più
molto più grosso nicol cazzo guardi
adesso ragazzi
e nessuno mi veda
de mita schierò questo cuscino
[Musica]
abidjan
cerchiamo di vedere il più possibile
però certe cose che non possono
registrare sito passiamo alla fermata
bellissima questo è un palo
questo è un tizio che professa la
religione comunque è veramente una cosa
che il tuo mette vede che ancora non ho
visto è stato sociali spacca perché si
vede nel riflesso che sta tenendo la
lago opposti leather
spero di sì comunque la finisco di fare
il [ __ ] se magari si muove il
semaforo dato macchinine che passano sì
sì sì sì quella è mia e quella mm la
mela me la stanno parcheggiando perchè
gli ho chiesto giustamente non c'è la
parcheggio fanno loro dovette vedere una
[ __ ] cosa siamo
quanti sono tra l'altro che professano
così quei cartelli troppi i capelli sono
sempre quelli c'è proprio la stesso
stampo
vabbè dicevo quella è la zona cioè
famosissima quella zona lì davanti dove
pieno di gente tra l'altro madonna
carnaio assurdo quella zona lì l'ho
vista 250 volte in gta quindi la conosco
sono di zona ragazzi
la mia piscina e le montagne russe su un
cazzo di ponte non l'ho mai cioè come
come sa fare le montagne su un ponte
e assurdo che io non ci andrei mai
io volevo stare a casa e canta volevo
stare a casa qui mi hanno detto ma primi
rilievi sulle montagne con lo so che
sono belle cazzo ok ok aspetta poi basta
[Musica]
mi sto divertendo
si no
[Musica]
a posto io nella mia vita ho visto di
tutto visto blog in macchina blog
rinunciato al ma blog in bici andando a
venice abbia mai fatto finora e più
pericolosa perché stupendo vinci con una
mano sola
quindi mischiatelo prese con stiamo
andando benino stile proprio il caso di
johnson di sant'andrea è veramente pivot
dovrei mettermi a fare i blog così io di
solito come quelli del sabato tutti così
vengo tutti i sabati qua bici mi prudeva
il naso sfilate noi e tutti saliti qua
in bici a fare il blog 51 scarpe nei
pacchi mi portò sono solo amici proprio
tale adesso posso passo avanti e più ti
limiti bella tutti i ragazzi a questa
bella tutti i ragazzi non si è girato ci
ho provato ragazzi volte questo vorrei
questo ragazzo
no lo voglio come personaggio di happy
days avanti lo voglio alimenti ragazzi
siamo siamo a disney l'hanno comprato
già la disney è praticamente poi vi
faccio vedere che cosa ho preso
giocattoli dei bambini e no praticamente
ragazzi siamo ci stava un giretto
all'adige prima prima di andar via
l'altro è morta la fontana caso però mi
sa che non abbiamo tanto tempo di
provare le giostre comunque starci anche
solo fuori è veramente figo cioè un
posto veramente bello poi dove posso io
si rompono le fontane e quindi ragazzi
può essere alle riprese non ho fatto un
blog della madonna come l'altra volta
perché stavolta tutto veramente
pochissimo tempo
spero che vi sia piaciuto talaltro
quando ero in coda per lo score del
blitz con alla fine quando sono entrato
ho comprato di tutto perché una volta
che ci andavo preso quello che potevo
mentre ragazzi ho preso questa che che
prevede un peluche daddy arson che fa
questo rumore bellissimo la mia vita è
completa dopodichè ragazzi ho preso
questo che è un po pop 10 non so come si
chiamano questo coso bello val collana
di arson che si illumina pure ragazzi e
bellissima tipo non è non siete stasia t
ok basta ipnosi per oggi ragazzi la
prossima volta ci prova seriamente
perché oppure ragazzi il telo mare con
la bandiera dell'alleanza di world of
warcraft avevano finito quella dell'orda
quindi ho preso direttamente questa
posso andare in spiaggia sentendomi un
nerd detto il resto direi che possiamo
passare al fa vi rispondo prima domanda
arriva da fabio [ __ ] il culo perché
ti sei chiamato fabio [ __ ] odio
bagaria il suo cognome però almeno fai
inglobato che casa all'ora ma poi ci fai
vedere tutti i capelli e pc che hai
preso 40 52 pollici in su più che più
che altro per il cognome più che per la
domanda però perfetto ragazzette pronti
perché sono sbattuto il gomito sono un
casino quindi preparatevi l'esca
le mamme one nannucci numero quando
questo è sexy significa number five in
cinghia lescot numero 6 con questo con
questo non vedo un cazzo
[Musica]
per concludere ragazzi il numero 8 che
il nuovo tra l'altro che è una roba tipo
io io posso andare in giro vai così
vedrebbe bellissimo economy lanzi una
lancia che prova lanci una lancia
proprio era pessima che è rosa ita
favismo ci farò un indovinello se
sbaglierei dovrei passare su instagram
una foto di tep che suoni la chitarra o
c'è un tipo di chitarra che si chiama
chitarra o probabilmente indovinello e
questo entri nella stanza a letto sul
letto trovi due cani e quattro gatti una
giraffa 5 compatta mi stanno intorno ad
esso tre galline svolazzano intorno c'è
una piccola anatra ecco quanti piedi
stanno nella stanza
2 perché i piedi sono letizia che nella
stanza non degli animali perché gli
animali hanno le zampe
e questi problemi o con da zero le cose
anche anche nelle interrogazioni ero
così nei fatti prendendo sempre due
cercherò di suonare qualcosa lo stesso
su instagram poi ci metto il video in
qualche modo lo faccio quindi ragazzine
che posso concludere qui prima di andare
prodotto fare l'affare domanda quali
domanda secondo voi ragazzi che cos'è
questa roba
c'era scritto allora facciamo che cosa
somiglia quest'anno errata lo sapevo che
cosa perché ho n'è andato su world of
work bordo world per tipo secoli quindi
lo sapevo però mai che cosa per chi non
lo conosce sa chicca che cosa somiglia
di preciso ha messo miglia a me a me
stesso quando mi alzo la mattina però è
che cosa vi ricorda voi questa è una
domanda strana però sono troppo curioso
di vederla risposto non lo so perché
quindi ragazzi che dire se il video è
piaciuto come al solito lasciate un
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come non i video tratta nella
descrizione sera siete faresti
destinazioni in ci vediamo al prossimo
video bella ragazza